[Musique]
ce job dating sera entièrement en ligne
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire donc
ça va être effectivement un ide job
dating avec donc des inscriptions
préalables on s'inscrit sur le site ce
qui emploie point fr et on peut rentrer
en contact avec des entreprises
présentent des institutions présentes et
on aura aussi des webinaires une
occasion pour ces jeunes de se former en
amont de l'événement avec des petits
ateliers qui auront lieu en ligne et qui
concerneront la manière de rédiger son
cv la manière de passer son entretien
[Musique]
certains secteurs qui redémarre
c'est le cas du numérique ces cas de la
santé c'est le cas des services à la
personne
c'est le cas du bâtiment tout l'enjeu
c'est d'aider nos jeunes a quand même
s'en sortir en misant sur ces secteurs
qui redémarre telles que je les ai cité
et on a beaucoup de jeunes qui subissent
vraiment cette crise de manière très
très violente et donc il faut les aider
[Musique]
c'est une manière pour le jeune de bêler
la théorie à la pratique
c'est une occasion pour lui de faire de
son alternance un tremplin vers l'emploi
un emploi durable et puis ça lui donne
une je dirais d'une carte en plus sur
son cv